okay let's go next to eduardo
from brooklyn eduardo from brooklyn
you're on the air
hi david hi how are you i'm good yeah
big fan uh thanks for doing this thank
you
uh quick question for you though is um
so as the vaccines kind of become a
little more
readily available um i was wondering is
there gonna be sort of sort of like uh
like a paperwork that you have to show
that you've been vaccinated or like
some sort of badge or whatever i assume
so yeah
we've already heard so the airline
qantas has already said they will be
requiring a vaccination certificate
after a certain point
if you want to fly with them
ticketmaster has said
they are building infrastructure so that
um
any any sports or concert venue that
wants to sell tickets with them
will be able to require a vaccination
certificate in some cases
it's a vaccination certificate or a
negative test within
you know a certain amount of time before
the event i um
i am hopeful that some american airlines
will say after a certain date you need
a vaccination certificate i i don't know
if it will be administered at the
federal or state level
there will be people eduardo who will
say this is mandated vaccination and of
course it's not it's only
if you choose to avail yourself of
certain private business
services you need to be vaccinated and i
think it's going to be necessary to get
more people vaccinated 40
reportedly don't want the vaccine and
that's a real problem
do you do you reckon though that if uh
like
that can be sort of like extended to
sort of
like a localized situation like bars and
restaurants and stuff like that
it certainly could be but my instinct
is that you know an individual bar or
business
is unlikely to pursue that that that's
my sense i think it'll be
you know airlines maybe some schools
um and uh you know employers could do it
if you're a really big employer
like a walmart for example you could say
listen we don't want
our employees falling ill nor our
customers getting the virus from
employees
so after a certain date if you want to
work with us you you need to have a
vaccination
that's certainly something a private
employer could do i'd be shocked
shocked if like individual restaurants
did it
sure yeah i mean for that we need the
vaccine for a simulation we need the
vaccine first
and uh you know hopefully we are we are
three weeks from it
fair enough uh thanks david and keep
doing what you do all right eduardo from
brooklyn
great questions uh vaccine talk love it
love the vaccine the vaccine is coming
and uh
that is you know that is something we're
all going to have to contend with
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire
thing i recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video